How is she doing that?
What am i missing?
Well, you're using a code editor.
So that's good.
But it doesn't really look like
you're taking full advantage of it.
You can absolutely do
exactly what she's doing, but
it's going to take
a little bit of practice.
>> You guys know I can hear you, right?
>> Hey Jenny.
>> Hey.
You're like five feet from me so.
Anyway, what Cameron's saying is right.
Learning how to code is like learning
a sport or playing a musical instrument.
It just takes time and
practice to get the muscle memory
you need to make it seem easy.
>> Yeah.
>> And
that's what this lesson is all about.
In this lesson you're going to
learn how to look like a hacker.
You will be taking full advantage of
your code editors to write code faster
and more efficiently.
Here, let me show you what you can do.